céleste et sylvain sont des nomades
sédentaires après dix années a
bourlingué à travers le pays chaque été
ils se sont posés sur un très
sympathique terrain de camping qu'ils
n'ont plus l'intention quitté avec le
temps ils ont accordé leur roulotte 1
puis à une fosse septique et même à
l'électricité par un fils sous terrain
ils ont aussi ajouté
jolie galerie mais ils viennent de
recevoir une bien mauvaise surprise un
compte de taxes de la municipalité
pourtant ils ne sont pas propriétaires
ils louent leur terrain au propriétaire
du camping
alors pourquoi eux reçoivent un compte
de taxes municipales parce que la loi
sur la fiscalité municipale permet aux
municipalités de taxer les roulottes
lorsqu'elles sont installés en
permanence sur un terrain même s'il est
loué le fameux l'histoire si votre
roulotte prend racine même sur un
terrain qui n'est pas à vous elle se
transforme en immeubles et peuvent
engendrer des taxes